So this is a big deal that this,
that this happens.
Now I want to tell you a little bit about the idea of the pillar because it's,
it's an unbelievably deep idea and it orients us in ways that we still don't,
it's still orients us in ways that we don't understand.
And in fact,
it's actually the mechanism by which we're oriented or,
and if it's lacking,
then we become disoriented.
And so I'll show you some pictures and describe them first.
Okay.
So first of all,
there's a walled city.
So let,
let me tell you that you could think about that as an archetypical human
habitation.
Maybe it's a reflection of something like a fire in the middle of the plane or
the forest or the jungle for that matter.
Although it's kind of hard to get a fire going there,
nudge in a fire,
ringed round with logs and perhaps ringed around with dwellings,
right?
So the fires in the center and the fire defines the center.
And then as you move away from the fire,
you move out into the darkness,
right?
So the fire is light and communion and safety.
And as you move away from the fire,
you move out into the darkness and what's terrifying out beyond the perimeter.
So what's beyond the perimeter is terrifying.
You can feel that if you go camping somewhere that's wild,
you know you're pretty damn happy.
Especially if the wolves are howling,
you're pretty damn happy to be sitting by the fire because you can see there the
fire keeps the animals away.
And you know if you do wander into the bush,
into the darkness,
then you're on alert and you know your Predator detection systems are on alert.
And so you could think about the classical human habitation as two places,
one where your Predator detection system isn't on alert and another where your
Predator tech detection system is alert on alert.
And you could think about that roughly as the distinction between explored
territory and unexplored territory.
And really the,
the founding of a place is precisely,
this is a lot of this I got from reading your Eliana,
the founding of a place is precisely the definition of a UN explored center set
against the unexplored periphery.
And you know what's interesting about that?
So you can kind of think about that with regards to the walled city,
right?
Everything in the wall is cosmos and everything outside the wall is chaos and
you know,
but it also extends to the conceptual realm because imagine that you're the
master of a field of study.
And so that's an interesting metaphor because the field is that a geographical
metaphor,
right?
And if in the center of the field are those things that everyone knows really
well,
the axioms that everyone abides by in the field.
And then as you move towards the fringes,
you get towards towards the unknown,
towards the frontier of the discipline.
And as you become expert,
you move from the center to the frontier.
And so then you're on the border.
When you're,
when you're,
when you're a scholar,
a competence call,
you're on the border between the unexplored or the explored an unexplored,
and you're trying to further that border.
So even if you're just doing this abstractly,
it's the same thing.
And it's a reflection of the fact that every human environment,
concrete or abstract,
it makes no difference.
Recapitulates the cosmos chaos dichotomy or the order chaos dichotomy.
And that's why endow isn't,
for example,
it's the union of chaos and order that constitutes being itself and that you
stand on the border between chaos and order because that's the proper place to
be too orderly,
too much in the explored.
You're not learning anything too much out there where the predators lurk,
then you're frozen with terror.
And neither of those positions are desirable.
So,
and that's what you know.
And so you think,
and this is a concrete reality obviously as well as a psychological reality,
there were reasons for those walls,
right?
Because inside the walls were all the people like us.
And so that begs the question,
what does it mean for people to be like us?
And then outside the wall of the rows,
all those people,
because they were the worst forms of predators because people are actually the
worst forms of predators who aren't like us.
And the wall is there to draw a distinction between like us and not like us.
And so,
and that was a matter of life and death.
You can tell that because I mean,
look at those walls.
They had to build those by hand.
And you know,
you do see walled cities that have three rings of walls.
So these people were terrified,
but not so terrified as the people who built three walls.
They were really terrified and they had their reasons.